-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
It's been two months since we
first left the studio
and we have heard some
of your criticisms
about our attic shows.
I want you to know that we
are taking it to heart.
So, as of today, there will be
no more reference to the copy
of "The Thorn Birds"
that is on my side table.
Just gonna be there, but I'm
not gonna talk about it.
And the number of books
is certainly
not gonna change
throughout the segment.
Also, I will no longer
be mentioning
the wasps in my attic,
but that's only because
we caught the last
two wasps this morning
and we have trapped them
in that door behind me.
Now, those are two real wasps
and not my sons dressed
in homemade wasp costumes,
who are gonna bust out
when this segment is over,
so, if you're stickin' around
for that kind
of adorable content,
you're wasting your time
because it is not gonna happen.
Two real wasps, not --
I repeat, not --
my two boys in wasp costumes
that I basically spent
the entire weekend makin'
because I have lost my mind.
Speaking of lost minds, segue,
the president is
reeling off fantasies about the
coronavirus just going away
after two West Wing aides
tested positive
and unemployment soared
to its highest level
since the Great Depression.
But don't worry --
he's also trying to distract
from the pandemic
by obsessing over the
Russia investigation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
It's rarely the case
that someone
as erratic as Donald Trump
is able to boil
all the venality, corruption,
and sociopathic incompetence
of his presidency
down into a single tweet,
and, yet, over the weekend,
he came pretty close,
although, in fairness,
he had lots of chances,
given that, on Sunday, alone,
he posted 126 tweets
and retweets,
including over 50 messages
before 8:30 am.
Sounds like it was
a great Mother's Day.
What did he have for breakfast,
pancakes covered in Adderall
and 10,000 Diet Cokes?
[ As Trump ]
Just like Mom used to make.
The president should not have
enough time to tweet that much,
even on a normal day,
let alone during a crisis
as nightmarish as this one.
It's not reassuring.
It's like
scrolling through your phone
on a flight
that's going through turbulence
and seeing your pilot
dancing on TikTok.
On Sunday, alone,
Trump lashed out
at everyone from the media
to celebrities, to Democrats;
retweeted random
conspiracy theorists;
and tried to fabricate
a totally made-up scandal
called Obamagate.
Even for Trump,
this was an especially
demented weekend on Twitter,
and that's saying a lot,
for a guy whose tweets,
generally speaking,
would make more sense
written backwards
on the door of a hotel room,
"Shining"-style.
And, as the U.S. death toll
from the coronavirus climbed
to nearly 80,000,
with unemployment at its worst
since the Great Depression,
Trump chose to take time
out of his day
to tweet about his own golf club
and use it as an excuse to both
advertise his personal business
and parrot his message that
the economy is ready to reopen.
Trump's golf course
in L.A. announced
that they were reopening
with a tweet that said,
"Game on!
We are thrilled
to announce the reopening
of @trumpgolfla
beginning Saturday May 9th!
We look forward
to welcoming you back
Book your tee time now!"
And then, Trump retweeted
it and wrote,
So great to see our Country
starting to open up again!"
Cool. I'm sure
the 20 million Americans
who lost their job in April
are stoked to hit the links.
"Honey, good news --
the unemployment check came.
Now, I can afford to play
three and a half holes
at Trump's golf course."
So, Trump actually found a way
to use a pandemic
to advertise
his luxury golf resort.
Reminds me of that time
during the Great Depression
when FDR advertised
his bindle-making business.
[ as FDR ]
Are you a hobo looking
for a sack
to carry your can of beans
as you ride the rails
in search of work?
Well, come on down
to FDR's House of Bindles.
The only thing
we have to fear is
these crazy-low prices.
No research went into figuring
out if he sounds like that.
Anywhere between 1,000
and 2,000 Americans
are dying every day
from the coronavirus
and, yet, rather
than confront that reality,
Trump is doing
the only thing he knows,
and that's lying
his way through it.
He's trying to dead-eye
mind-trick Americans
into thinking coronavirus
will simply go away.
On Friday, he told reporters
that the coronavirus
would soon disappear,
even without a vaccine.
-This is gonna go away
without a vaccine.
It's gonna go away and it's --
we're not gonna see it again,
hopefully,
after a period of time.
You may have some --
some flare-ups and,
I guess, you know,
I would expect that.
Sometime in the fall,
you'll have flare-ups, maybe.
Maybe not, but, according
to what a lotta people say,
you probably will.
We'll be able to put them out.
You may have
some flare-ups next year,
but, eventually,
it's gonna be gone.
It's gonna be gone.
You know, there are
some viruses and flus that came
and they went for a vaccine.
They never found the vaccine
and they disappeared.
They've never shown up again,
They die,
too, like everything else.
They die, too.
-Holy [bleep]
Your strategy for dealing
with coronavirus is,
"Eventually, everything dies"?
Are you responding to a pandemic
or narrating
a Werner Herzog movie?
[ as Herzog ]
Time is nature's
cruelest weapon.
Ze clock is an assassin
silently stalking us
to ze grave
with his sinister laugh --
tick-tock, tick-tock.
I guarantee you Werner
is crushing stay-at-home.
No one thinks coronavirus
will just go away,
let alone without a vaccine.
You already tried
this bull[bleep]
before this pandemic started
and it didn't work
back then, either.
-The virus.
They're working hard.
Looks like, by April,
you know, in theory,
when it gets a little warmer,
it miraculously goes away.
[ Chuckling ]
I hope that's true.
Now, the virus
that we're talkin'
about having to do,
you know, a lotta people think
that goes away in April
with the heat,
as the heat comes in.
Typically,
that will go away in April.
-Nailed it again, Dr. Science!
Not only is the virus
still here,
it didn't even get warm yet.
On that note,
[bleep] off, April.
What was that?!
This year of all years.
Who told you coronavirus
goes away in April?
Are you confusing it
with March Madness?
[ As Trump ]
The madness spreads
to basketball courts
and college campuses
across the country,
but don't worry.
It goes away in April,
when either Duke
or Villanova beats it.
Trump is selling
yet another unhinged fantasy
to try to coax people
out of their homes
and back into the economy
after two West Wing aides
tested for coronavirus
and The Washington Post reported
that all White House staffers
received a memo
from the White House
Management Office on Friday
which encouraged employees
to practice maximum telework
and to work remotely,
if at all possible.
Well, that's easy for Trump,
since he's already spent
the last three years teleworking
from his home office
on the 18th green at Mar-a-Lago.
Every time you see him
in the Oval Office,
that's just his Zoom background.
Think about that --
the president is telling people
to get back into the workforce,
while his own White House
tells employees to stay home.
One day, he's gonna call
a press conference
to reassure us that
murder hornets are fake news,
while a dozen of them
carry him back to their nest.
[ Buzzing ]
"You live with us now, Donald."
And don't let mention
of the murder hornets
get you to thinkin' that my kids
are in that door back there,
dressed like wasps,
'cause they're not,
and they're not gonna just
barge out at the end
of this "Closer" --
I'll prove it.
I'll prove they're not there.
Who wants ice cream?
They're not there, guys.
They're not there.
And, by the way,
you'll never guess
how Trump reacted to the news
that one of his staffers
had tested positive
for the virus
he failed to contain.
After learning that one
of his valets was infected,
Trump became lava-level mad
at his staff
and said he doesn't feel it's
doing all it can to protect him.
First of all, look at 'im.
He's always
lava-level something.
If he's not lava-level mad,
he's lava-level happy,
or, more often than not,
lava-level indifferent.
Second, Trump is actually upset
that the people who are
supposed to protect him
are doing a good job.
Oh, the irony.
If we were living
in a story or a fable,
this would be the moment
where the mean old miser
finally has a change of heart
and throws money at some kid
to go buy a goose [ Laughing ]
for the festival or something.
But this is Donald Trump.
There's
no change of heart.
There's no learning curve.
If this was a Choose
Your Own Adventure story,
the bottom of every page
would say,
"Unh, just --
just go to the next page."
The president is just
profoundly incapable
of thinking about anyone
other than himself.
That much has been clear
from day one of this crisis
and it was on full display
when he called in
for his latest
teletherapy session
with the Fox & Friends
on Friday.
This was the day
the government announced
truly catastrophic
unemployment numbers
and the coronavirus death toll
climbed toward 80,000
and, yet, the president
rambled for 20 minutes
about God knows what before he
even talked about coronavirus,
and that was only because
the Fox & Friends
finally asked him about it.
-Mr. President,
good morning to ya.
-Good morning.
-Hi, Steve.
They know it was just
a total hoax.
It was a made-up story,
a disgrace to our nation.
These are dirty politicians
and -- and dirty cops.
So, Schiff is a crooked
politician, crooked as can be,
probably one of the worst
I've ever seen.
I've seen some beauties.
It was like they just sat there.
They sat in an office.
"Hello. Goodbye."
That would be a meeting.
You look at Mueller,
that was purely corrupt.
And can you imagine,
with all the corruption
having to do with Mueller,
you don't have Clapper;
and Brennan, who's sleaze;
and a guy like Comey,
who's a sick man.
-Right.
I mean, Comey's a sick man.
He's just a stupid guy.
-Well --
-He's dumb as a rock
and he's a sick guy.
There's something wrong
with him.
We've rebuilt our military.
This is not what
they love to hear.
Jeff Sessions was a disaster.
Well, Kislyak had dinner
with Nancy Pelosi and Schumer,
all these guys, they all,
everybody in Washington
knew Kislyak.
But I learned a lot
from Richard Nixon --
Don't fire people.
I learned a lot.
I study history.
If you did a poll there,
[ Laughing ]
I'd do very well in the FBI.
But the top was crooked.
They were dirty cops.
-Someone get grandpa
off the phone.
Every time Trump calls in
for one of these,
we can only see
the "Fox & Friends"
sittin' there, blinkin',
like a family
who accidentally bought tickets
to the wrong movie.
[ Whispering ]
"Does this whole thing
have subtitles?
Is this a subtitled movie?
'Cause I don't --
Where's Vin Diesel?
I thought -- I thought
this was Vin Diesel."
They're like a family
of tourists at Art Basel,
staring at a banana
duct taped to the wall.
"Is it supposed
to represent life?"
"No, I think the message
is that bananas..."
-Die, too, like everything else.
-Trump is just deeply,
clinically, incapable
of summoning even
the bare minimum amount
of empathy required for the job.
For example,
in that same interview,
he was also asked
if he had a message
for America's mothers
on Mother's Day.
Now, this was an especially
difficult Mother's Day
for so many,
with Americans are separated
from loved ones
and struggling amid a historic
unemployment crisis
and public health emergency,
and, yet, the president
reeled off an answer
so deranged,
it's actually hard to fully
appreciate just by listening.
So, instead of playing
his answer,
we're gonna read
the full transcript.
First, here's the question.
-Mr. President,
this Sunday is Mother's Day.
What are your plans?
What are you gonna do
for Melania
and do you have a message
for all the moms that are
watching this morning?
-Easy, right?
It should be a gimme.
Answering that question
is like getting 200 points
for writing your name
on the SATs.
For an impeached,
historically unpopular president
in the midst of a catastrophic
public health crisis
and soaring unemployment,
getting a softball lobbed
at you like that
is like goin' 10,000 points
in the red on "Jeopardy!"
and gettin' the category
Food That Comes in Buckets.
[ As Trump ]
Oh, finally, something --
This is my wheelhouse.
Alright.
This is a question
any president, or any mammal,
should be able
to knock out of the park.
Even a dolphin
could whistle and click
their way through this one.
Instead, our drooling
potato-brained Caligula
had this to say,
in response to a question
about Mother's Day.
And, just for some ambiance,
let's throw a frame
around the screen
while I read this.
Here it is.
Ahem!
[ Piano plays tender tune ]
"Well, we'll be together.
I'm going
to a Camp David meeting,
a big meeting,
with the Joint Chiefs of Staff
and Camp David is
this very special place
that nobody ever gets to see,
but it's a great
work environment
and we're gonna have meetings
on different things.
And our military has
never looked better.
It's never been better.
We never had the kind
of equipment we have now.
And, you know, we had planes
that were 50 years old
and more, fighter jets.
Now, we have the best
in the world,
the F-35 and the F-18.
And, you know,
what we have is incredible.
The equipment and the people
we have are great.
But, you know,
they have to have equipment.
And we've spent $1.5 trillion --
really, more than that --
and we've totally rebuilt
our military,
which you have to do.
You know, I'm a very
budget-conscious person.
It's what you have to do.
The nice thing --
it was all built in the U.S.A.
and plenty of equipment coming.
A lot of this equipment
is coming.
So it's very important that
we have the best military
and we have the --
our military has never been
in condition like it is now,
and soon will be."
Wow!
I'm pretty sure
even a F-35 pilot
can write his mom a card
without mentioning the F-35.
Seriously, that answer was more
revealing than a CAT scan.
Based on that answer, alone,
a doctor could diagnose
like five different strokes.
Sometimes I like to imagine
what would happen
if Trump were, let's say,
one of the 100 people
interviewed
for an episode of "Family Feud."
Like if the category was
Things You Do for Your Wife
on Mother's Day.
Both team would strike out
and then the host would say,
"Top 5 answers were -- brunch!
A card!
Flowers!
Chocolate!
Fighter jets, fighter jets,
the jets are coming,
Joint Chiefs, the military,
the greatest military
you've ever seen,
equipment, equipment,
we have so much equipment,
the equipment is coming,
military, military,
the best military, the military,
I love the military!"
We're currently in the middle
of a deadly pandemic
that has been made worse
by the sociopathic incompetence
of an impeached president
who is fundamentally incapable
of grasping the responsibilities
of his office and, now,
he's trying to distract
from that
by trying to undo
the Russia investigation.
Last week, his attorney general
and Mafia-themed Bobblehead
William Barr announced that,
in an unprecedented move,
the Justice Department
would withdraw charges
against Michael Flynn,
Trump's first
national security advisor,
who twice pled guilty in court
to lying about his contacts
with Russia's ambassador
to the U.S.
-Attorney General
William Barr's DOJ
is dropping the charges
against the president's
former national security
advisor Michael Flynn.
This comes after Flynn
pleaded guilty
to lying to the FBI
about conversations he had
with the Russian ambassador
and cooperating
with investigators
and it comes on the same day
that one of the lead
DOJ prosecutors trying Flynn
took his name off the case.
And we've seen this before.
It's something we saw happen
in the case
of another Trump ally,
who also got favorable treatment
from the department --
Roger Stone.
That time, the DOJ stepped in
and reduced his
sentencing recommendations
against the recommendations
of their own line prosecutors.
-The Department of Justice
is basically just an arm
of the Trump campaign now.
The Trump campaign store is
gonna start selling pardons,
commutations,
and sentence reductions
alongside these
very real items --
MAGA pet leash, MAGA dog collar,
and USA camo dog bandanna.
By the way, if you see a dog
in MAGA pet leash,
call the ASPCA.
Sarah McLaughlin
will come get the dog
and it will be taken away
and the...
♪ Hands of an angel ♪
Just the best.
Like this part of the acoustics
just makes, I think,
my voice come alive, in a way
you don't get in the studio.
Trump always wanted
a loyal attorney general
and, now, he's got one
in Bill Barr.
The president is rage-tweeting
about exacting revenge
against his political enemies,
as a pandemic
craters the economy
and touches his own White House
and, on top of everything else,
he's incapable of summoning
even the bare minimum
level of empathy
for the people affected
by the crisis.
We don't need a test
to tell us he's a...
-Sick guy.
There's something wrong
with him.
-This has been "A Closer" --
Oh, no.
Oh, the wasps are out!
Oh! The thing we wanted
to happen least, happened!
These are real wasps.
These are not children
in wasp costumes. Oh, no!
-[ Laughing ]
-Oh, no, he's stinging me.
Oh, God.
This is a nightmare!
Oh, everything has gone
from bad to worse!
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no! Oh, no!
Who are you?!
Are you a wasp?!
-I fly --
I can fly -- Whish!
-This has been "A Closer Look."
Can you say, "This has been
'A Closer Look'"?
-[ Speaks quietly ]
-What?
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-City Harvest needs your help,
now, more than ever.
New Yorkers who have never
imagined asking for help
are now turning to them
to keep food on their tables.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands.
We love you.